an exciting night for spencer
watkins his major league debut came on
friday today his first big league start
and
he has defied the odds just to get to a
big league mount the only player
from the 30th round of the 2014 draft to
make the big leagues the 910th
overall pick marcus simeone the blue
jays second best on base percentage man
with his 34th walk of the year
simeone at first here comes bo buchet
the o2 and a ground ball base hit
through the right side
for beshette simeon will make the turn
and
race into third and a very promising
start for the blue jays runners on the
corners with nobody out
so a great early opportunity for the
blue jays first and third nobody out for
vladimir guerrero jr
first pitch from watkins swung on and
lined to left field
but it is caught on the warning track by
hayes simeon can tag and easily come
into score
on a long sacrifice fly by guerrero his
70th rbi
on the season and it's one to nothing
blue james
springer on the ground to short could be
two ureas gets one
veleka will not get two not quite in
time to get springer
runner goes hit on the ground to third
it's fielded by leiba
he throws to first to take care of
hernandez
and the first inning is over 15th start
of the season he's 7-3 with a 460 earned
run average this is his first
career start against the orioles and the
two spot for the orioles is their left
fielder austin hayes
that ball driven out to left field
pretty well hit and guriel just
missed it off the bat hayes is going to
go to second he
is in there he was going to hold it
first
it was a bad throw by guriel it took
simeon off the bag
and a really heads-up play by hayes to
get into second base mancini coming up
to the plate
fly ball well hit deep center field
springer
is there right on the edge of the track
to make the catch about
400 feet away two down and hayes stays
at second
ground ball to third biggio's throw is
in time to get a mount castle and the
inning is over four in a row retired by
watkins
and now here's randall gretchen
did he go he sure did so spencer watkins
first big league strikeout comes against
randall grichard
spencer watkins a 10-year deal for
getting that guy out yeah
that is a baseball that requires
authentication
he's gotten the first two outs here of
the second inning blue jays with a one
nothing lead and it brings up pedro
severino
the o2 swing and a miss and matt strikes
out pedro severino
as he sets down the orioles in order end
of two
and a walk for bechet the second handed
out by watkins tonight
one out base runner in front of vladimir
guerrero jr
fairly well located pitch for 2-0 gets
one out of it
and a double play
on a 2-0 count to vlad guerrero jr
spencer watkins cool as can be
papaleka will lead off the bottom of the
third one nothing toronto
this one grounded a high and hop snared
by beshead and his high throw
is too high guerrero couldn't get the
foot down in time and balaka reaches to
start the home third
so here's the switch hitter domingo laba
laba cracks one to left field
and there's domingo laba's first hit at
camden yards
back-to-back singles first and second
with nobody out in the bottom of the
third for cedric mullins
and the one-two and he got him right on
the outside corner again for strike
three call
and mullins is the first out here in the
bottom of the third no two
and a swing and a miss at a fastball up
above the zone
two down runner's still at first and
second here's trey mancini
good change up there and he gets a lazy
fly ball to right grichik is there
a very nice job by steven matz after the
first two reached base
one to nothing blue jays going to the
top of the fourth it'll be george
springer
3-2 for springer and george tied up
he did go strike three and spencer
watkins picks up his third strikeout
so two outs now spencer watkins pitching
to randall grichick always dangerous
and i'll have a chance maria's to
valencia
four innings one run against the major
league's second best offense
bottom four the blue jays won and the
orioles nothing it'll be the
four five six hitters for baltimore and
a swing and a miss
fastball again two out base hit for
motorists here is pedro sebarino
severino rockets one out to left field
deep and
on a two-strike pitch a blast from pedro
severino to jolt the orioles into the
lead
his fourth home run of the year that one
off the bat right at 108
407 feet almost a line drive getting out
of here well if spencer watkins can do
away with bo buchet
and get through five biddings of one run
ball this would be
one of the pitching highlights of this
orioles season hit
on the ground right side kicks up to
valencia second
baseman to first they get the out how
about you spencer watkins
five innings a one run baseball against
the blue jays
so domingo liban now against stephen
matson
leyba on a hop to shortstop pachette has
to make a long high throw and beau
buchette is just in a funk right now in
the field
laba hustles it out and he's a board in
the bottom of the fence watch out he
just kind of winds up
gets real long most short stops more
quicker armstroke 15th error against
pachette
let's see if cedric mullins can take
advantage
cedric mullins first pitch blast off
into right field at the wall
and good hey now
he is an all-star number 16
for cedric mullins and the hits just
keep on coming
well are you not entertained i mean
cedric mullins
what else can he do and the mullins
homer ends the day
of steven mass trent thornton
right-hander will come on and replace
him with the orioles
with two men in scoring position and
santander who has
grounded out and popped down and that's
in the dirt kicks away
here comes trey and he'll score standing
two and two against santander and a fly
ball
crank to right field he will get that
run in and one more
a colossus of a home run from santander
party on utah street it's 7-1
108 off the back when you talk about it
no doubt this is anthony santander power
randall richard leads off the seventh
for the blue chase down seven to one
dylan tate's still on the mound for the
orioles
and grichik sends one to deep left field
and it is
gone about five rows deep home run
number
16 on the season for randall grichik it
is 7-2
something about the baltimore orioles
that
randall critchett just lights up every
time here's a good matchup vladimir
guerrero jr against the the big arm
of tanner scott and a swing and a fly
ball to center and deep
mullins to the wall it's gone
a bomb to straight away center field by
guerrero number 28 on the season
and it is 7-3 he can get to anybody's
fastball and
hit it a country mile going to the ninth
it'll be tyler wells
to look at biggio grid